okay so this is our scale everything
starts from here well we have this
14-foot tall creature and we have to
figure out how we're gonna fit four
people an entire rig and all those
mechanics that are inside of it so what
we do is we will take the rough frame
that we did put three people on that and
then take pictures a Nintendo type of
video reference scale references that we
need and then we will superimpose it on
the artwork so that we can get a better
idea of what we're working with what
specific volumes that we need to like
abide by right about there we'll use
Pete's feet as our baseline like that
other than like what CG artists have to
deal with we work in the real world
everything has volume everything has
space and in order to be able to figure
all that stuff out we have to start
somewhere
thirty-eight then we want that 113
stay in school kids so you need it to
make monsters badge number point three
to know what do we say thirteen and a
half that's to top the eye and then we
can kind of scale it in and go okay
that's how big that arms gonna be it's
nine feet long
Wow
it's almost like the the thing that was
playing in my mind actually is we're
gonna need a bigger boat I'm just
looking at this thing is like wow this
is an achievement I think this is the
largest puppeteer creature that we've
ever made
comic-con fans are gonna go nuts want to
see more go to wired.com for the entire
giant creature series